you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is another
group of five puzzles in each of them
it's white to play and it's up to you to
determine the best continuation so go
ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation for white ok
the solution to puzzle one is first
Bishop g5 double check and keep in mind
from the original position white is
already down a queen and so attempts are
trying to go after the black queen are
not best we can do better as white and
that is to go after the black King from
here with the king being and double
check he must move and if he tries to go
to e8 we deliver mate with rook to d8
and if the King tries to go to c7 we
once again make use of d8 only this time
with the bishop so that the King cannot
run to the b6 square so this first
puzzle was actually a checkmate in two
and so moving on now to the next one
white to play pause the video see if you
can find the best continuation ok the
solution to this one is not to
immediately take the pawn taking the
pawn to give check while it might be
very appealing since the king is already
running very short on squares the knight
is there to defend however once you
recognize this maybe you can first
remove the defender Queen takes Knight
is the best move delivering check if the
King tries to run the bishop grabs the
pond and that will be main the only
other thing to do is to take the Queen
and now only at this point do the
bishops now control all of these squares
and this is checkmate so once again
another checkmate in two puzzle moving
on to the third one white to play pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation ok the solution to this one
is first between the f8 and there is
only one reply but ship takes Queen and
now finishing up Knight g7 and this is
checkmate since both rook and Knight are
hitting the King once again double check
and there's no place that the King can
run to that is safe so these first three
so far we're checkmate in two puzzles
moving on to the fourth once again white
to play pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation ok the
solution to this one is a quiet move to
start
Queen h4 and there's not a good solution
to the main thread on h7 if black tries
to blunt this diagonal with that five
that would drop the Queen and this is
really the main thing because anything
else well we're just going to be mating
on each seven so this is turning out to
be maybe the best move at this point I
guess there's some sacrifices to delay
the inevitable on h2 but eventually
black will be forced to play off six and
give up the Queen or in short Queen h4
is the best move in this puzzle and keep
in mind that if you weren't playing
Queen h4 maybe a reason for you to not
see that is because you weren't making
use of the full potential of the Queen
try not to just have her functioning as
a rook but also address again all of her
potential work her along this diagonal
the h4 to d8 diagonal so Queen h4 is the
solution to puzzle four and moving on to
the fifth and final once again white to
play pause the video see if you can find
the best continuation okay the solution
to this last one is King in the corner
and the idea here is that if now Queen
takes bishop this is actually stalemate
so of course important to recognize that
there is not a way for white to win this
position taking the Queen well the King
is of course too far away this is just
completely waiting for black so you have
to make use of a stalemate idea King to
h1 and any other black King move while
you're just dropping the Queen so this
is really going to be the best play for
black at that point and I guess as a
bonus question if there is some time it
was some type of a bonus question that I
could be throwing out at this point if
I'm to ask you if black does not capture
the bishop does black lose this position
yes or no if you'd like to pause the
video and think about it for a little
bit and I'll just give the answer okay
if black does not capture the bishop
black still does not lose for example if
the King goes to any one of these three
let's just say here bishop takes
this is not a win for white because if
you can envision this pawn is already
being passed that queening square is a
light square the bishop needs to be able
to control it and because he does not
there's not a way to push this pawn
eventually to to Queen and so you know
white wouldn't be able to win from this
position but nevertheless you wouldn't
see that type of a thing from this
position King Navy which one is the
solution and we just end up in a drawn
position after Queen takes bishop so
that's all for this video as always let
me know how you did in the comment
section below and I'll catch you in the
next video take care bye